of course the Oscars that's the big
story and there was one particular
moment from last night's Oscars everyone
is talking about today it came at about
one hour and 42 minutes into the
broadcast that's right I think you all
know what I'm talking about there was an
incredible performance by I think this
year's biggest breakout star check this
out
you see McDonald's new one two three
dollar menu I have never feed with those
things
candy earrings cheeseburger and a medium
coke for a dollar each you know what I
don't have any money I don't have any
pockets on this dress that's okay I got
you this time you're at the best Chrissy
Teigen just gave me these earrings
freeze it right there okay ladies and
gentlemen that is Cathy Yamamoto who's
also the writers coordinator here at the
show this is very exciting now as you
can imagine every late-night show tried
to book her but we were the ones that
got her tonight
so without further ado the Oscar for
Best Performance in the McDonald's
commercial by a current current employee
goes to Cathy a Valero
Oh
Caffe as you can see we went to great
trouble we got you a real Oscar statue
for your performance it says best
editing 1955 yes that's right it's sound
editing we got it at an estate sale I
think the winner died wow this is so
exciting
I'd like to thank everyone on Team
Yamamoto my agent my mom my boyfriend
and of course my co-star Chrissy Teigen
hashtag Squad hashtag model hashtag
Fitness hashtag Cali lifestyle that's
great that's great
Cathy just curious will you be moving on
now that you've hit the big time
absolutely okay did you uh did you
already booked another gig no I just
don't like it here that's very
unfortunate you're very needy and
require a lot of validation okay that's
great and the snacks here suck ass right
Cathy Yamamoto everybody
[Applause]
I did not know she booked a commercial
she's here every day it's amazing see
her every day she's one of them in there
in the writers room taking down all our
ideas I'm watching the Oscars and there
she is
yeah I went out for that I went out for
that commercial
didn't get it all right
excellent show tonight when I say I
didn't really go out for that commercial
I'm sensing people in the audience
feeling sad for me no I did not
there's another commercial I went out
for I did not get okay we'll talk about
that later it's for that lady leg shaver
anyway let's talk about tonight's show
because that's what we're really I have
beautiful legs
you